hello there and welcome to Playstation
grenade
it's update time once again in fortnight
battle royale and week three has brought
us new things to blow our puny Minds if
you knew around these parts this is the
series in which we check out all the map
changes and secrets in the world of
fortnight so sit your butt down for 10
minutes slap cold Adam are you in the
star to support this madness and think
about subscribing please fortnight
chapter 2 season 3 week 3 let's go
[Music]
I'm not starting with Hut watch this
week I know I know it's insane but this
is even better right now the new desert
island has been added to the very top of
the map this place tells a story by the
looks of things and it will evolve each
week as these things go through the
human stages of history from the wood
Age to the Stone Age
and finally the Industrial Age of a
metal age to keep it in line with what
we can build with if you remember
rightly the crustaceans once had this
entire area of the map
they were happy chappies it was a fun
place with music playing and happiness
at all times they even got a front row
seat at the Travis Scott concert but
then Midas inadvertently brought us the
flood of biblical proportions and these
poor minions were left stranded some
stayed under the waves
but others set up new camps over on
piranha island and used the rubbish dump
as the ground beneath their feet
well this week another tribe has
appeared and have set up a very small
perimeter fence from what can we take a
quick moment to admire the woodsman here
he has a little Viking axe you look so
cool what a star and over on the other
side of the island it looks like there
is going to be a Viking crustacean
wedding happening very soon I never
thought I would say that in my entire
life oh well by interacting with the
village the world evolves to see more
settlers arrived in Viking longboats
structures updates and just look at the
detail there's a blacksmith there's a
well there's lockout towers and the huts
have little Patrick's and Koopa Troopa
shells for cover
I love little details next time we come
back here I'm expecting the village to
upgrade to the Stone Age and could we
see the crustaceans wage war on those on
piranha island
either way this guy is gonna win any
battle he's Thor the fungus all we need
now he's dead Bob thaw
okay I've resisted long enough we have
to do this watch is evolving my friends
and this week is a huge week we can now
confirm that this is not the usual Hut
structure we saw in previous seasons
this is more like the chair house at the
Old West world only chapter one oh geez
remember that place
what watch is hopefully gonna be double
thick and towering high into the sky
moving inside this brilliant building it
has multiple rooms being created as we
speak and integrating those chairs that
fell all the way from the cliff edge all
those weeks back do you remember that
I'm hoping so much that this spot
becomes important to the game but in the
meantime I'll be sat at the cafe taking
in the sights
now here's your opportunity if you want
to look like you work for Epic Games try
to predict what this thing will look
like what will it become let's check
back on all this in a fortnight here's a
great update the no sweat building which
can be found in lazy lake has been a
great place to get hints about the
future it has already told us about the
flood and how it would protect each part
of the island and now it's telling us
about the vehicles we're expecting very
soon the posters around this place show
a variety of cars and trucks with my
personal favorite this one which I am
told is named after you you're looking
good mud flaps yes I just cost you mud
flaps AIA subs I have no idea why I did
that I'm very sorry to add to this the
gas stations now have signs above them
both on the map and in-game so you know
where to collect fuel for your vehicles
that will definitely impact gameplay the
next updates are challenge related have
you spotted the Rings floating in spots
around the map can we note how close
they look to Sonic the Hedgehog's golden
rings
imagine a sonic crossover I know it
isn't going to happen but I can dream
about these things how cool would it be
and how good does that ring look a
bigger update will be for our incoming
aquaman skin around the island in replay
modes at least we can find a trident of
trident it's no secret we all want the
weapon from
comic books and film and now we are one
step closer and to foreshadow this check
out Deadpool shots to see new graffiti
foreshadowing that trident also it's
great to say that the Marvel character
is still here even though this season is
focused around a DC character usually
those two companies stand off each other
and will not get involved but now we
could have Deadpool vs Aquaman I'm so
down to see that my money's on Deadpool
in fact today's poll Deadpool vs.
Aquaman who wins over in sweaty sands
we've seen many construction vehicles
move in and last week we saw a tugboat
being loaded with materials this week
those mats are firmly on board and the
raft is about to set sail I am
completely clueless on where this will
be going it will likely be more apparent
when the sea levels update and drops
down a little we'll see that hopefully
later this week I've start of next week
more Island should be revealed very soon
a few more changes have come in in the
update designed to change the game's
flow for example chopper spawn rate has
lowered and this is represented in game
right now our Lord and Savior Graham the
genome at his Shack you'll notice the
helipad has vanished
it's just straight-up gone rip the dream
speaking of Graham though I don't
believe there is any update to note here
about the gnomes and bears so hit me up
if you see anything hang on where are
they
where's where's the raft with the white
flag and the games and the drinking and
the telescope II think I've totally lost
them I beg you to help me something has
taken them was it the crustaceans was he
a game bug or was it the Kraken my
screen is shaking guys but seriously
where could they be
sunken I suppose maybe scattered around
I need your help here
I can't bear it yeah dad jokes I also
checked on the gnome all alone by the
golden toilet and he's still here all
normal own okay no more dead jokes
they're terrible
here's an update many people have asked
me to document so we've all seen the
little Chester's these little guys made
from dummy arms and legs attached to a
chest did you know we can find where
these parts have come from thanks to
this trash island here what's more
interesting is the dummy head a legit
crash-test dummy is here could we see
this become a skin in future it makes
sense as somebody at Epic has made this
person their legs their arms their toss
over their head it can't be just to bury
them here can it I'm pretty confident
crash test dummies will have more to
offer in the future what do you say
would you buy a skin like that I would
if it came in pink as well as all this
positivity there is something we need to
bring to the light if you haven't
noticed already news has broken that the
game mode which birth fortnight battle
royale has officially come out of beta
woohoo
and isn't full release save the world
the crushing thing to note is that the
game is not expected to have any more
support no new storylines just the
occasional event which is quite gutting
to be completely honest I use that game
for much of my law and storyline videos
in Battle Royale because they offered so
much potential and possibilities well
we'll have to see what happens but
judging from the press release that game
has been
and I'm pretty damn gutted about it to
such a degree that saved the world is an
added extra when you buy a skin rather
than the other way around but I guess
they had to end at some point the
strange thing is though this season some
of the default characters were updated
to include a save the world logo on
their arms and even the Marauders are
taken straight from save the world
anyway before I sudden myself too much
let's go back to positives in other
great news the return of LT M s are
coming this week we've missed them and
we need them so thank you so much epic
please bring back the floor is lava
pretty pretty please and to confirm no
update at the bunker this week no update
with the Lost Ironman either
truckasaurus is still laying dormant
exactly in the same place and the urinal
warrior hasn't changed position either
I'm not sure about that name but he does
have a chest inside his stomach for when
the water levels finally drop by the way
I'm planning on making a story video
next week and wanted to give you all the
opportunity to contribute but because
there's so many comments it's very hard
to actually see all the really good
ideas so if you want to contribute
please write hashtag theory in your
comment at the start so I can quickly
find it and put your ideas alongside
other people's ideas and we'll smash
them together to come up with six new
stories for this time next week how does
that sound
I think that's the update this week what
have I missed like always check them in
the comments and I'll make sure they are
in the next episode on screen now are
the leggings roll call people who are
kind enough to use my cold I really
appreciate thank you very much for
choosing me I know there are thousands
of great creators out there and you
chose me makes me feel all special thank
you kindly I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade been a pleasure I'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]